we now know the man set to lead japan as
the country's next prime minister fumio
kishida has won the governing party
leadership election and is set to take
charge of the world's third largest
economy we're aiding its recovery
post-pandemic will no doubt be top of
his agenda let's bring in our asia
correspondent tom cheshire tom he's uh
calling for more fiscal stimulus he's
also quite hawkish on china isn't he
yeah all the candidates really were in
terms of the diplomatic and security
side on the economic side he really is a
sort of continuity character he's a
familiar face
from a very familiar party he's pretty
much ruled japan on inter with only a
couple of interruptions since it was
formed in 1955. but he was up in the
last round against harikano the popular
vaccines minister uh he was seen as more
internationalists he had promised to
sweep away a lot of the bureaucracy um
but what we got from uh mr kashida
instead was an emphasis on a new type of
capitalism he hasn't spelled out what
that means yeah and as a result we did
see shot uh stocks fool um after this
announcement so perhaps the market
reacting to that i think he is aware
that um he is this familiar face when he
was uh speaking to the press a bit
earlier he said that um although he was
well known this is a chance for a new
turn for the party
i want to firmly show a reborn liberal
democratic party to the japanese
citizens and urge them to support us
from today i will with all of my energy
get straight to work party members
around the country and members of the
parliament please work with me
you he will have a fair amount to do on
monday he'll uh is certain to be uh
elected as prime minister in the
japanese parliament uh but then there
has to be a general election before the
end of november and it's it's going to
be interesting to see what effect that
really really has on the japanese public
um given he doesn't have that sort of
popularity that the vaccines uh minister
had given that he's coming after
yoshihide sugar who resigned because he
was so deeply unpopular things are a
little easier for his successor the
vaccination rollout starting to work the
olympics although there's a lot of
trepidation before they happened uh were
seen as a success but all eyes now uh on
the post pandemic recovery and perhaps
that's why the party has gone for
someone who they really know and they
think will keep a steady ship in what is
going to be a difficult period for japan
and the world
all right tom thanks for that